[Music]
change the order of the world
the times that await us will be
radically different from those we
have lived in our lives with
therefore similar to those of the distant
past how do I know because it has
always been like this
[Music]
in the course of my  about 50 years of
global macroeconomic investment
I learned the hard way that the most
important events that amazed me
surprised me because these painful surprises never occurred in
my life
have led me
to study the last 500 years of history
in search of similar situations and
see and had really occurred a
long time ago with the ups and downs
of the Dutch
British
and US empires
and every repetition
was a sign of the changing order
of the world
this study taught
me valuable lessons and I am going to pour into the
readings in form  distilled you can
find the complete version of my
book the changing order of the world
I want to start with  story that
brought me to this point that of how
I learned to predict the future by studying
the past
[Music]
in 1971 when I was a young clerk
in the wall
street trading room and the United States ran out of
liquidity and defaulted on
its debt is  what happened the
united states were left without money as
well then for transactions between
nations they used paper money
for example the dollar was like
the check of a passbook that is without
value outside the possibility of
exchanging it for gold which was  the real
money at the time the united states
spent much more than they
earned I take many more of these
checks in the form of banknotes than
it was to meet the value of the gold
held in the bank
as the owners of these
little creatures presented in the bank to
have them in  change the amount of gold in the
usa dwindled
it soon became obvious that the united states
could not deliver on its promise
conversion of all paper money
so those who owned dollars ran to
change me before the gold ran out
recognizing that the us would
run out of real money on
sunday evening of august 15th
president nixon appeared on tv to tell
the world that the us would no longer
honor  the promise to exchange one's
dollars for gold
using terms appropriate to the
circumstance says it more diplomatically without
making it apparent that the united states
was insolvent the strength
of a nation's currency is based on the strength
of that nation's economy and the
american is  by far the strongest
in the world as a result o instructed the
secretary of the treasury to take the
necessary measures to defend the dollar
from speculators
i asked the channel secretary to
temporarily suspend the
convertibility of the dollar into gold or
other reserve assets except
for  quantity and conditions
established in the interest of
monetary stability is n  In the best interest of the
United States I was shocked to
understand that the concept of currency
we familiar has ceased to exist
in crisis
I expected the stock market to collapse the
next day so he shows me in the room
early to be ready when I am the
opening bell it was pandemonium
but not the kind I held the market
was very positive
and continues to rise almost 25 percent
surprised me because I had never
witnessed a devaluation of the
currency
when I went to consult the
history texts found that the exact same thing
had fallen in the  1933 with the same exact
effect even then paper dollars
were tied to gold that the us were
running out of
because they spent more banknote checks
than they could convert to gold
and president roosevelt announced on the
radio that he would violate the
nation's promise to convert dollars  in
gold it was then that I put the proclamation that
instituted the forced
national closure  of the banks and this was the
first step the government took to
rebuild our economic
and financial fabric the second step
last Thursday was the law promptly and
patriotically passed by congress
to confirm my proclamation and
expand my powers in such a way that it
became possible  in light of the
time requirement, extending the
forced closure and
gradually eliminating the prohibition that that
closure entailed in the
following days, the law also gave the
power to develop a program in
both cases, breaking the bond with
them allowed the united states to
spend more than the proceeds  simply
by printing more paper dollars as
there was an increase in the number of dollars
without increasing the nation's wealth
the value of gold dropped
as these new dollars entered
the market without a corresponding
increase in productivity they ended up
employed in buying an avalanche
of shares  gold commodities though  miliprocessed
with consequent rise in prices by
studying the history again vidic is
exactly the same had happened many
times in the past alive that
since the dawn of time when a government
spent more than it got from
taxes and conditions worsened
ran out of money and
increased the need to have it
therefore there was a large increase in the
quantity of paper money with consequent
south pricing and an increase in the price
of almost all shares gold raw materials
and semi-finished products.
securities
stocks or commodities in anticipation
of their increase in value and the
depreciation of paper money
printing of money and also what
happened in 2008 to alleviate
the debt crisis triggered by mortgages and in
2020 to alleviate the economic crisis
caused by the pandemic  and almost
certainly will be repeated in the future
Fr.  so my suggestion is to keep
this principle in mind these experiences
have given me another principle which is
the following to understand what you are
going to encounter it is necessary to understand
what happened before this
principle led me to study how
the bubble of the roaring years
twenties turned into the depression of
the 30s from which the elections that
allowed me to predict and exploit the
bubble of 2007
which became the collapse of 2008
all these experiences lead me to
develop an almost instinctive desire to
look to the past to find
similar situations and learn how
juggling in the future changing orders
[Music]
in the last three years three great things
that hadn't happened in my life led me to
undertake this study
first nations did not have
enough money to pay their debts
even after they were reduced to zero for  one hundred
interest rates so their
central banks started stam  it seems large
quantities of paper money to
replenish it second great
internal conflicts emerged and the reason for increasing
differences in levels of wealth values ​​this
manifested itself in politics in the form of
populism and polarization between the
left that wants to redistribute
wealth and the right that wants to
defend the rich and third  the growing
external conflict between a rising great power
and the existing great power
as it is now in the case of china and it is customary
then to look back then i saw that
all these things had already happened
together before many times and almost always
led to changes in
national orders and  international the last
time this
succession was presented was from 1930 to 1945 it
would be natural to ask what
exactly is an order is a system that
regulates the interrelation between people of
are internal orders for regulation
within nations normally
set out in constitutions  and there is a
world order for  regulate
relations between nations normally
stipulated in treaties internal orders
change at a different rate from
that of world orders and
regardless of whether they are
within nations changes normally
occur after a war and
civil
wars within international wars between
take place when new revolutionary forces
defeat old weak orders for
example the internal order of the usa was
established in the constitution of 1789
after the american revolution and still
works today even after the
american
civil war russia liquidates to its old order
and into quads or a new one with the
russian revolution  of 1917 which ended in
1991 with a relatively
peaceful revolution China and established its
current internal order in 1949 when
the Chinese Communist Party won the
civil war
I wanted to sketch the concept of
the current world order commonly
called world order according
to america  is constituted after the
allied victory in
world war ii when the united states
imposed itself as a hegemonic world power
impacts and contracts were stipulated
governing the conduct of business
between states and monetary systems in 1944
the new world monetary system was
outlined with the bretton
woods agreements and assigned to the dollar  the role of the world's
leading reserve
currency a reserve currency is one that is
normally accepted around the world
and having one is a key factor in a
nation that is set to become
richer and more powerful empire
once a new
dominant power is established is a  monetary system
begins a new world order
these changes take place in a
timeless and universal
cycle we call the be cycle the big century I
will start with a quick review and
then expose a more complete version and
finally direct the reader to my book
if you wish to learn more
when I studied the ten most powerful
empires of the last 5  00 years and the last
three reserve currencies I have covered the
history from the birth to the decline
of the Dutch empire and the
British empire florin and the pound sterling
the initial rise of the
US dollar empire and the decline and
rise of the Chinese empire  and its
currencies and also the birth and decline
of the Spanish German French
Indian Japanese Russian and Ottoman empires
with their significant conflicts
measured in this chart to
better understand the Chinese patterns I have
also studied the birth and fall of
the Chinese dynasties and their
backward numerary  up to the year 600 since
examining all these measures at
once can be confusing I will focus
on the four most important
the Dutch coin the British the
US the Chinese wall soon to
notice the pattern
now let's simplify the narration a bit
as you can see they took place in  These
superimposed bodies lasted about
250 years with transition periods of
10-20 years  between one and the other
normally these transitions have
been periods of great conflict because
the hegemonic powers do not disappear
without fighting
therefore as I measure the power of an
empire
in this study I used eight parameters
the measure of the total power of a
nation derives from their  media they
are
education inventive technology development
competitiveness in global markets
product in an economic
sense world trade share military strength
the strength of their financial center
for capital markets and the strength
of their currency as a reserve currency
since these values ​​are measurable
we can  see how strong each nation is
now as it was in the past and whether it
is rising or falling
by looking at sequences from many nations
we can see how a typical cycle plays out
and as the tiny
swings can be confusing we can
simplify the picture a bit to
focus  on the pattern of
cause and effect relations ch  and move the rise
and fall of the typical integer as you can
see better education
normally leads to more
innovation and technological development and
with some delay in the affirmation of
money as a reserve currency
it can also be seen that these forces
later marry  in a similar order
reinforcing the decline of each other
let us now look at the typical sequence of
events that take place within
a nation that produces these ups and
downs in simple terms the bic cycle
normally begins after a great
conflict often war strips the
new power  hegemon and the new
world order since no one wants to challenge
this power normally follows a
period of peace and prosperity
as the population served
this peace and prosperity more and more
relies on its persistence
borrows money for that purpose
and eventually comes to  create a
financial bubble
the trade share of the
empire expands and when the
most of the transactions and
conducted in its currency this becomes
a reserve currency that leads to
even greater indebtedness at the same time
this greater transferred
distributes wealth unevenly
so that normally between rich and poor
the inequality grows
sooner or later the financial bubble  explodes
resulting in the printing of money and
greater internal conflict between rich and
poor leading to some form of
revolution for the redistribution of
wealth this can happen
peacefully or with a civil war while
the empire is engaged in this
internal conflict its power  waning in relation
to external rival powers on the rise
when a new power on the rise becomes
strong enough to compete with the
dominant power that is struggling with
internal collapses external conflicts
normally of a war nature take place
from these internal and external conflicts
new victors emerge and  losers
the winners met  to create the
new world order and the cycle
starts all over again
when I looked back I saw that
these cause and effect relationships
fueled the cycles of rise and decline
going back to the Roman Empire
I saw how the stories of each of
these cycles were mixed  with others
before, during and after
in the same way in which every single
story mixes with others to compose
the history of the five hundred years
handed down to us which is our collective history
and with the cycles of human life
they do not exist identical but are however
more similar  they are driven by
cause and effect relationships that advance by stages
from birth to the vigor of maturity
to arrive at weakness and
inevitable decline
however it is like saying that the
life cycle of a person takes 80 years on
average without recognizing that many are
much shorter and  many are much
longer if on the one hand age can be
a good indicator of future longevity
on the other a mig method  liore is
considering health indicators
you can't do with empires and also with
their life parameters I found that by
looking at the indicators
of power change I could
see what stage a nation was in
which helped me predict what is likely to be
there.  'was around the corner now
I will take you through the bic cycle in
greater detail give me
20 minutes and I will illustrate
the last 500 years of history showing
you the similar patterns that unite the
Dutch British US
and Chinese empires
500 years vidic cycle I will
describe the typical cycle  dividing it
into three phases
the rise the apex and the decline
the rise
new successful orders both
internal and external that arise are
normally founded
by power revolutionary leaders who do
four things first accumulate power by
garnering more support than
the opposition  second they consolidate
their power by converting by weakening by
eliminating the opposition so that n  n
hindering their path third they
establish systems and institutions that
make the nation work well and
fourth they choose carefully their successors as
well as have ways that facilitate it
because a great empire requires many
great leaders over several
generations
at this stage
right after I have won the  struggle
normally there is a period of peace and
growing prosperity
because whoever is in charge is in clear
control and broad consensus that no one
questions at this stage the
leaders within the nation must
design an excellent system to
increase wealth and power  of the
nation first of all to be great they
must have a profound education that
is not only knowing how to teach and do it with
ingenuity but also a
strong savoir faire character and work ethic
these things are normally taught
in the family in schools and
religious institutes are at the origin of
healthy respect for the rules the law
of order in the society of a ba  sso
level of corruption and united for a
common purpose work well together
in doing so increasingly evolve from the
production of basic goods to innovation
and invention of new technologies
for example the Dutch rose to the
point of defeating the
Habsburg empire and excelled in culture
they became so advocates of innovation
that they produced a quarter of
the world's greatest inventions, the greatest of
which was the ocean-going ship that
killed great wealth and
capitalism
as it exists today to finance
those voyages
and since all the hegemonic empires
refined their thinking by keeping
open  to the best thinking in the world
as a result the inhabitants and the nation
became more productive and more
competitive than world markets which
was demonstrated in their growing
economic output and increasing share of
world trade
this can be seen to take place now that
the United States and the  china are
roughly equivalent either  for
economic production that for share of
world trade
as nations trade more
globally they protect their
trade channels and foreign interests
from attacks therefore they develop great
military strength if well done this
virtuous circle leads to strong
income growth that can be used for
finance investment in education in
infrastructure and research and development
must also develop systems to
incentivize and emancipate
those with the ability to create or amass
wealth in all these cases the
most successful empires used a
capitalist approach
to develop productive entrepreneurs
also china  which is ruled by
the Communist Party of China used a
form of this capitalist approach
[Music]
deng xiaoping when they questioned
him about it he said it doesn't matter whether the
black or white cat as long as it catches mice
and
be rich and cause for glory to
do it well must develop  their
capital
markets especially their
bond and
stock lending markets this allows the population
to convert and save into
investments to finance
invention development
and participate in the successes of those who
make great things happen
the Dutch created the first company
to  shares the dutch
east indies company is the first
stock market to finance it i.e.
integral parts of the system that produced
enormous wealth and power
as a natural consequence the major
empires developed the main
financial centers to attract and distribute the
capital of the world
amsterdam was the world financial center
when the dutch were the
ne plus ultra
london when the british were at the
top
new york is now and china is
rapidly developing its
financial centers especially the capitalists
the executive and the military must
work together
not only the dutch did well
together they
were one
the company of the Dutch Indies was
granted a commercial monopoly by the
government and being able to have their own
military body authorized by that
executive to go to the global markets
to produce amass wealth
the British
followed suit with the
British company of the Indies  oriental and
had a similar coordination with the
operations of their
corporate government and the military apparatus the US
military industrial complex was
the next and today it is up to the Chinese system
as the nation rises to
greater
international trading empire its transactions
can be paid for  in the
national currency so that this becomes the
preferred medium of exchange and since its
currency is accepted so widely and
frequently it begins to be put aside
making it the preferred store of value
and thus the largest reserve currency on the
planet
the guilder was the main
reserve currency of the world when gl  the dutch
were at the top of international trade
the pound was at the time of the
british and the dollar is since the
united states are at the top of course
the currency of china and increasingly used
as a reserve
currency having a reserve currency allows the
empire  to borrow more
than other nations is a huge advantage just
think for a moment all over the world
people want to save or
lend their money
for the empire nations without a
reserve currency don't have this power and
when the empire runs out  its currency
remember the united states in 1971
can always go back to printing the
exorbitant privilege that confers the
reserve currency of the empire pushes
the debt to rise and triggers the
financial bubble
these cause and effect relationships in which
the political and military financial sectors
are  they support each other
reinforced by the power and leverage
offered by the reserve currency are
intertwined
all the empires that have reached the
highest peaks have followed this
path
[Music] since the beginning of human history,
the vice being in the apex phase,
the forces at play are for the most
part in full force and the  fruits of
their success contain the seeds of
their decline as a rule the inhabitants of
these rich and powerful nations have
high incomes which make them more
expensive and less competitive in
comparison to the inhabitants of other nations
willing to work for less at the same
time as the inhabitants of others  countries
spontaneously copy the methods and
technologies of the hegemonic power
which further reduces their competitiveness
for example the English shipyards
had less expensive workers than
the Dutch ones so they hired
Dutch designers to design
better ships that were built by
English workers with lower economic demands.
it made them more
competitive by leading to ascent
moreover, when individuals get
rich they tend to work less
assiduously they have more free time they
cultivate superfine interests that are
less productive in life and they reach
an end of decadence
the values ​​change from generation to
generation in the course of the descent
to '  apex from those who had to
fight to achieve wealth
the power to those who inherited them
are less tempered by the struggle immersed
in luxury had the easy life
which makes them vulnerable to
harshness
the golden age of the Dutch empire
is the  Victorian era of the British
[Music]
[Applause]
were periods of high prosperity like
this as people get used
to the dhabi well-being and more assume
that the times continue and go
into debt in that belief by creating financial bubbles
naturally earnings  financials are
distributed unevenly and the
inequality increases the disparities of the
r  Weaknesses tend to get stronger because the
rich use their greater resources
to consolidate their powers for
example they grant more privileges and
children like better education and bend
the political system to their advantage
this causes gaps in the
political axiology and
growth opportunities among the rich  and the dispossessed
the less well off and they believe that the
system is unfair and resentment
grows but as long as the living standards
of most are growing these
inequalities and resentments do not
result in a conflict
holding the reserve currency of the world
inevitably leads to
excessive debt and contributes
to  'accumulation of huge sovereign debts
to foreign lenders
while this stimulates spending power
in the short term
weakens the national financial health by
weakening the currency in the
long term
in other words when indebtedness and
spending are intense and strong
in the empire but its  finances are
actually  à
lumicino debt sustains the power of the
nation beyond any sensible criterion by
financing itself for the internal hyperconsumption
that the international military conflicts
necessary for the maintenance of
the empire inevitably the costs to maintain and
defend the empire exceed the revenues
that therefore generate an empire
becomes uneconomical for example
the Dutch empire expanded
excessively all over the world and
fights increasingly expensive wars with
the English and other
European powers to protect its territory
and trade routes
in the same way the English empire
became bureaucratic and lost
its competitive advantages as
rival powers notably
germany soared into an
increasingly expensive arms race
and world war the united
states spent about $ 8 trillion
on foreign wars and their
aftermath since 9/11 and others
trillions for other military operations
to maintain military bases in 70
nations and still do not spend
enough support of
military competition with china in the
geographic area close to china in this
cycle the wealthiest nations
over time sink into debt
by borrowing from nations
poorer with more savings is one of the
signs of the change of hands of the
wealth of power this in the
united states started in the 80s when the
per capita income was 40 times that
of china and started
borrowing from the chinese who wanted to
save in  dollars because the dollar
was the global reserve currency
in the same way the British
borrowed a lot of money from their
much poorer colonies and the Dutch
did the same when they were at
its peak if the empire begins to run out of new
financiers those who hold the
currency  they start trying to sell
liquidate rather than buy
save lend and
pledge  arsi
[Music]
and the strength of the empire begins to
decline
the decline
the decline comes
from internal economic weakness coupled with internal struggles
or costly war conflicts or or
both
normally comes gradually and then
suddenly
when debts have escalated and
c  'it is an economic overturning empire is no
longer able to borrow the
money necessary to repay
debts
the financial bubble explodes
this creates great internal difficulties and
forces the nation to choose between
the insolvency of its debts and print a
lot of new paper money the choice
always falls in the press in large
quantities initially for serious and then in
massive quantities
this devalues ​​the currency that drives
up inflation for the Dutch it was the
financial crisis caused by the
financial excesses of the payment of the fourth
Anglo-Dutch war
in a similar way for the British the  the collapse
was attributable to the financial excesses
of his debts incurred in the two
world wars and for the us
these are three cycles of
debt-financed booms and collapses
since the 1990s with central bank interventions
each time with stronger measures
when the government encounters problems in
raising hedge funds when there
are bad economic conditions and
living standards for the population
are falling and the distances for wealth,
values ​​and political positions are great
the internal conflict between rich and poor
and also between different ethnic
religious and racial groups increases dramatically
this leads to political extremism
which manifests itself as populism  of the
left or right, the left
aims to redistribute wealth
while the right to keep
wealth in the hands of the rich
normally at these times
the taxes payable by the rich are increased
and when the rich begin to fear of
losing wealth and well-being they
move to  places or buy
divided goods where they feel safe quest  and
escapes reduce the tax revenue of the
empire which leads to the classic
self-feeding process of
emptying
when the flight of wealth becomes
too strong the government forbids it those
who were looking for a way out
begin to
panic these conditions of  disorder
have a vacation effect on
productivity that shrinks the
economic pie and causes more conflict over
how to spread out and scarce resources
populist leaders sprout at
both ends and pledge to
take control and restore order this
is where democracy is  more
questioned
than invalid defense of anarchy and the
likelihood that a strong
populist leader will be elected to move from
cause to maximum order
as conflict escalates
within the country
some form of civil war revolution develops
to redistribute  wealth and
strengthen the necessary major changes
can take place peacefully  entity and maintain
the existing order or more frequently
with violence and change of order
for example or the
roosevelt revolution to redistribute wealth
was relatively peaceful and conservative
of the internal order while the
French, Russian and Chinese revolutions
were much more violent  and led to the
new internal orders this internal conflict
makes the empire weak and
vulnerable to external rivals on the rise
who seeing this internal weakness
are more likely to raise the
challenge and therefore risk the great international conflict
especially if a rival has a
military apparatus  comparable to defending
oneself and one's empire from rivals
requires large military expenditures which
must take place when
domestic economic conditions are under stress and
the empire can less than ever afford it
as there is no efficient method of
peacefully
settling international disputes are
normally resolved  with pro
As the challenges become more
daring, the hegemonic empire must decide whether to
fight or retreat to
fight and then lose the worst
of choices but it is also to beat a
retreat because there is progress and
rival and signals that the  empire is weak to
those countries that look and choose for
whom to side poverty causes a lot
for the wealth and power that
inevitably brings some form of
war wars are tremendously expensive
at the same time they produce the
tectonic movements that realign the new orders
to the new  reality of wealth and power
in the world when those who hold the
reserve currency and debt of the
declining empire lose confidence and sell them
we have reached the end of the South Dec cycle
of the approximately 750 currencies that existed
since the 1700s, less than 20 percent remain
and  all were devalued for the
Dutch it occurred after the defeat of the
Fourth Anglo Dutch War when they
failed to repay the huge debts  i
accumulated during the war
this led to a run on
the bank of amsterdam and a
desperate sale and massive printing of
paper money
to the point of depreciating the currency and
the empire to become insignificant
for the British this is what happens
after the second war  world when
despite their victory they
failed to repay the massive debts
incurred in the war effort which
led to paper money
devaluations and sell-offs of the pound
sterling as the united states and dollar emerged
creating a new world order
at the time of this registration and the
united states  have not yet reached
this point despite having a huge debt
while spending more than they earn and
while financing this deficit with
greater indebtedness and an
abundance of paper money
the great sell-off of dollars and
dollar-denominated debt has not yet begun and while
there are  great internal and
external conflicts for everyone  The classic reasons
have not yet crossed the line that
transforms them into wars with the passage of
time from these violent conflicts or not
new winners emerge who unite
and restructure the debts and
political systems of the losers,
establishing the new order of the world,
therefore the  old cycle and empire ends
and a new one begins and everything is
repeated
or brushed for your benefit many
details to show you how
a typical be cycle takes place
obviously not all of them materialize
exactly in this form but
mostly it is what happens to the point that  the
parables of rise and decline are
all alike and the only things that
change are the clothes worn by the
protagonists and the technologies they use
then where we are headed
[Music]
the
future empires for the most part have
their period of splendor and  inevitable
decline
countering the decline is difficult
because it requires the undoing of many
things done but it is possible by
looking at these  It is very
easy to see what stage of the bi
xenon the empire is in when it is
fit and if its better or worse condition
which can help to estimate how many
years it has yet these estimates
are not accurate and the cycle can be
prolonged  if those who are in
command position pay attention
to vital parameters for example knowing
that a person 60 years old how healthy he is if he
smokes and some other essential biological sign
allows to estimate his
life expectancy
it can be done with empires and also
with  their life parameters will not be
precise but also indicative and will give
a clear indication of the measures to be
taken to extend their life it
happens very often that the greatest
war of a nation is with itself
without making the necessary difficult decisions
and maintaining success
as for what we have to do it comes
down to just two things earning more
than we spend and treating
each other well  other all the other things
mentioned serious education and inventive
competitiveness and all the rest are just
ways of achieving these two things is
simple and recognizing if we are
doing them so as individuals who
want to keep fit we follow the
program and improve our
vital signs let's do it
individually  and as a group
the goal I pursue to share
this picture of how the world works
and some principles necessary to
treat it well is to help you
understand where we are and what challenges lie
ahead and to make the wise
decisions necessary to
easily overcome these times
[Music]
because there is so much more to discuss
and time is running out you can learn
more from my book the changing order of the
world and i look forward to continuing
this conversation in economic
principles punto jorge on social media
thank you
may the strength of evolution be
with you
[Music]